foreign
[Music]
Cancer Institute at the University of
Texas at Austin
and today I'm going to present you a
project I have been working on on the
systematic characterization of the Sea
of the genoculatory adversary wiring
patterns mediated by non-colian region
structurbations
the idea is that we are able to
construct an individual cell in
regulatory Network to study how the
regulatory mechanisms change when there
is a non-core ingredient particles
the to construct an individual cells in
regulatory Network reconstruction
currently the most used tool is systemic
a Scenic is has been seated more than
1600 times and it takes into account
certain assumptions that are not totally
biologically accurate for example it
only works with transcription factors
that are seen in the demonstration
Matrix and it is the correlation metric
that the use is positively defined since
they work with random forest and
examination of trees and the
transcription factors of the activity of
the transcription factors is returned as
a binary Matrix where the transition
factor is active or not
so this is in this agreement with the
biological reality because the
transcription factors are typically
lowly expressed they are hardly seen in
the genus relation Matrix of single
Serenity data because the large
amount of dropouts that we see in that
data type the transcription factors also
can be
activators or repressors of the gene
expression of the genes and then these
is a this requires a metric that allows
for positive and negative values and
also the activity of the transcription
factors is dependent on the
concentration that we observe in the
cells so the most of the transcription
Factor the mass of the activity in there
and this is something that is means in
the output of a Scenic so in order to
account for those changes we recently
developed a tool called scorpion
scorpion stands for single cell oriented
reconstruction of panda base
individually optimized networks and is
an implementation of the panda algorithm
from single Cellar energy data so the
panda algorithm is an optimization
algorithm that use message passings to
integrate different data types in this
case protein productive interaction
transcription Factor motif in the
formative region of the genes and a
single cell gene expression data so the
correlation structure of this gene
expression is take into account to
update or integrate all the information
together to generate a Refinery
regulatory Network that ensures the
agreement of all the biological data
that we have access to
the in a scorpion we are able to assess
the activity of all the transcription
factors even if it is absent
and we ensure that the metric that we
use accounts for the directionality of
the of the regulation so transfusion
factors can have an activator
activity or a repressor one also
transcription factors are accounted to
be concentration dependent and it we use
a continuous metric for that and we also
account for the cooperativity of the
transcription factors by the information
that is provided with protein protein
interaction
so the first thing we did with the
Scorpion was to evaluate this
performance and for this purpose we use
a tool called be line V line is a tool
design specifically to test the
performance of generator Network
construction algorithms and by using
VLAN we were able to compare the
performance of Scorpion against 12 other
algorithms so in the blood and the right
side of the slide you guys can see that
a scorpion outperforms all the other 12
aggressions and it provides the higher
Precision record Curve Metric with an
increase of at least 20 percent of the
performance
and
you compare with others is Scorpion is
also faster and it also provides more
information about the motifs that are
present in the levels
so because they
information provided by B-Line is too
small and don't recapitulate a real
biological uh
experiment we decided to apply a
scorpion on two different experiments
that contain transcription Factor
perturbations the figures one is a
double knockout of two transcription
factors that Define the identity of the
enterocytes the hnf4 alpha and Gamma
transcription factors when we construct
two networks for each one of the cases
one for the wild type and the other for
The Knockout we found that there is a
chief on the weights associated with
these transcription factors and those
Chiefs are consistent with the
directionality that was targeted in the
word lab so there is a down regulation
or a decrease in the weight as we see in
in those
in those weights of the transcription
factor and Target the interactions and
when we compare the differences in the
specific Target genes we found that the
top ones at the bottom of the list the
most down regulated ones are in fact
associated with the markers that Define
the identity of the stereocytes this
confirms the authors of the data set
claims and also confirms the ability of
a scorpion to identify changes in the
transcription factors and the specific
Target digits to account that this
carbon is also able to identify other
regulations of the transcription Factor
activity
we use a recently published
that doesn't that includes a stem cells
treated with the over expression of two
foreign transcription factor and by
doing this we construct also two
generator networks one for the wild type
and another for the overexpression of
distance fiction factor and where we
compare the weights we found a chip that
is also consistent with the experimental
design the chief is in the positive side
so all the weights are larger than they
were before of the respiration of the
translation factors and when we compare
the differences in the effect over the
target genes we found that the ones
associated with the identity of the mark
of the AC cell like are in the top of
the list so they are in fact upregulated
so by using this information then we
decide to
use another tool that was developed by
my sqga called lioness and when we
combine a scorpion with lioness we are
able to construct a Sim an individual
regulatory Network so these Individual
Services in regulatory networks are
important because they allow us to
associate different covariance of the
information so in here in this slide we
see the network shoe that is a family of
tools developing development Institute
that accounts for different techniques
and different
a
experiments that can be done over the
network that are constructed using the
panda algorithm and it's also display
the formula that is used to construct an
individual
cell generator so to test
the performance of this combination of
tools we decide to apply it over this
data set the GSE
185995 and this dataset was designed to
account for the
of the human genome in
breast cancer cell line so the
experimental design is that the authors
of the data set generated a
set of single guys rnas and then they
infected the cells and they guide RNA
will cause a perturbation in the
non-going region of each one of them and
sadly there is no individual Association
so we individual
preparations of the of one guy that RNA
by one cell there is a combination that
approximately 30 guys rna's personal in
at least 50 000 cells so we use this
information as generated uh individuals
and in regulator Network for each one of
them
in
and then we we moved to to that analysis
and we found that
in the data set after quality control
there are 54 000 cells and the
distribution of the number of guys rnas
based per cells are displayed in the
panel a in the panel B we have the
distribution based on the ucis
a feature types and we see that most of
the perturbations are located in known
regions are not very well characterized
the others are in the promoters and in
the enhancer regions and we also
evaluated the differences of the
transcription factors motifs in each one
of the promoter regions and we found
that the the top five most more affected
will be sp1 and all the others displays
in the panel C
when we take into account the in degrees
of the network we con we we use this
information to constitute the low
dimensional representation of the data
and this is displayed on the panel d as
you can see the phenotypes that we
observe after the perturbation converts
to a limited number of phenotypes that
are defined for each one of the Clusters
and as you can see at the top of the
panel B There is a cluster in dark blue
it means that those cells we
hypothetize that those are the wild type
group because they are close to
not having any guys RNA on it and the
effect of the phenotype is defined in
them
so the Second Step that we did was to
identify the associations of each
position of the perturbation in the
headsets in this plot and the
association with the changes in the
transcription Factor activity on the
y-axis so as you can see here the
minority of the associations that we see
are in blue that means that when the
transcription fact when the non-coin
regions are perturbated the effect of
the transcription factors is down
regulated and this is consistent with
the
idea that the authors of the data set
are targeted by targeting the flanking
regions of the well-defined enhancer in
cancer
and others that are labeled in red that
have the minority are known as an
insulators and those are associated with
the down regulation of the activity of
the transition factors but when you
pursue them of course they will allow
the cells to overexpress them so we
tested each perturbation and identify
whether what transcription Factor will
be the most effective one
then we move to identify the
effect of the perturbations
over each one of the target genes and we
identify a set of genes that are often
more frequently affected by these
perturbation we focus and identifying
and characterizing each one of the
perturbations positions based on
different epigenetic markers
that are shown in the range of this plot
and also we Define each one of the lens
weight and the different types
so in this way we are able to know which
perturbation in which regions of the
genome are associated with differences
in the in degree of the network when it
happens so we then were interested in to
know if there is was an association
between the position of the perturbation
in the Earth's axis and the position of
the transcription star site for each one
of the genes
we found that there is not a direct
Association of a guy that RNA Target a
of guided RNA perturbation and the more
affected Gene so not because we
perturbed the closest
non-colline region of again we will have
that Gene specifically as a
significantly pertured and we found that
still there is an enrichment of the
disease regulatory mechanisms but this
one is not that highly different to
other trans regulatory elements so this
is important because we found that even
though the promoter region is the most
important
or the most important section of the
genome to
they modified the expression of the
genes the
unknown regions that are still not very
well characterized are ranked as the
second one and there is no statistical
defense in in their in the differences
of activity so we see that the enhancers
are not that effective on uh regulating
them but they are not very well defined
for this kind of cell line so for that
reason we wanted to
investigate further and I develop a new
data set where we can actually identify
causal associations of the network
rewiring patterns
so because these data set that we used
before does not have enough cells with a
single guy RNA on it it makes difficult
to
model the association between each
observations and each one of them
rewind patterns I wish in the networks
so we decided to generate a new crispr
screen on simple cell transcriptomes
using crop sick and use the same cell
line but to
Target individual perturbations in each
one of them the we sequence 18 000 cells
that some of them were removed after
quality control
remove
a the cells with mitochondrial content
about the 10 percent and those that
failed out of the 95 confidence interval
for the regression against the number of
genes based on the level of expression
and we identify 1200 cells carrying a
single guy RNA that allow us to test the
the division effect of 48 defined a
enhance so we generated the figures that
are these planes in the panel A2 you
display the mitochondrial content in the
panel B to identify the number of genes
per cells the number of guidelines
person in the panel C and the similarity
between the links in between the guys
rnas that are observed in each one of
the cells as you can see there are two
main clusters that contain cells
carrying a single that RNA so these two
are suitable targets that in use the
proliferation of the cells have they are
interested when
to understand how these perturbations
regulate these
early phase
so
as a conclusion we introduce the
Scorpion algorithm that is an
implementation of dependent in
regulatory Network because the general
algorithm for single Serenity data we
showed that we constructed individual
cell generational words on the different
Crystal preservations
we found several non-coin regions in the
genome that disrupt the transcription
Factor activity and the expression of
the target genes we found an enrichment
of six significant associations with
interpreterations close to the genes
promoter regions and we found
differences in the rewind patterns
between different fissure types
emphatizing and the importance of
characterizing the genome non-coin
regions
and that is all for today thank you for
having me